President Biden's pet dog Commander
biting yet another secret service agent
the injured officer was treated by
medical personnel at the White House and
is said to be doing okay it's the 11th
agent Commander has chowed down on since
becoming part of the first family in
October that is an unflat picture of
picture is so crazy I don't get it is
that dog on coke what's wrong with that
dog it was his baggy picture maybe it
was his bad no apparently it's anxiety
driven I saw an animal is afraid he'll
be attacked as the progressives are all
over look you know we attack dogs now
this story is ripe for mockery but you
have to understand this is progress in
Biden's white White House the dog bites
man but in Obama's White House it was
man bites dog yum wait what remember he
ate dog in
Indonesia oh come on Jessica keep up
with your dog eating oh no that dog
can't live in the White House anymore
what are they doing how many people does
he have to bite before get rid of I mean
these poor and the Secret Service people
are focused on like I hope the dog
doesn't bite me instead of watching the
President that's the
problem I mean they covered up the
cocaine you'd think they'd not bite him
they'd owe him thank you this is why
he's going to lose the election all
right I was listening to Tik Tok Radio
on Sirius SM today they had a guy come
on in between songs and say the
president can't say LL Cool J and his
dog has bit 11 people it's over once it
breaks through like that it's over so in
Jesse I know yeah wow and she says that
sincerely I you guys are really blowing
my mind everyone's comments on this hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else